i haven't spent as much time with the
rock as i'd like to i think he's a
fantastic human being
but man can he cook and man it smells
good
hi i'm john cena this is sport bible and
now is the time where fans ask questions
and i give answers let's do this which
actor would you want to play you
in a film about your life i'm
able-bodied
i still have my wits about me a lot less
vision a lot less hair up top but
i can still tie a tie in a half windsor
i'm looking for work
yeah i'd do it yeah sure i'll take the
part i'll play with myself i'll play
by myself i'll play i want to act as me
in a movie
about me what's it like to be hit by a
chair
it feels like getting hit
by a chair
will there be a follow-up to your rap
album i don't know are you deaf yet
because if you can't hear then there
should be a follow-up to my rap album
but if you can i don't know maybe i
should just leave it as it was
can you give us a rap line can i give
you a rap line i don't think that's one
of your questions i think
you're asking that these are fans asked
questions and i'm not going to say that
you're not a fan
but you kind of breach as a host so i
don't want to say it's a conflict of
interest
but i'm going to say it's a conflict of
interest and that question is
disqualified
did i ever smell what the rock was
cooking multiple times
and i mean i haven't spent as much time
with the rock as i'd like to i think
he's a fantastic human being
but man can he cook he made this
sous-vide venison loin once it was just
it was otherworldly i mean it's my first
introduction to that style of cooking
but
i can never master it it's the bag and
the fluid and
i just don't get it but the rock does
and man it smells good
who would win in a fight between myself
and vin diesel you could see who would
win in a fight
dom or jacob toretto in the upcoming
film fast nine
but in a realistic scenario vin's wise
beyond his years
and i'll take wisdom and experience any
day i've had my share of matches but
they're wwe matches their rules and
stuff i'd give it to vin on this one
what is the most dangerous wrestling
move so i'm going to interpret the
question as what's the most
dangerous wwe maneuver hmm
a debate that has been going on since
the dawn of time
i will say this i'm actually invisible i
don't know if you know this
i can do this and if i say the magic
words while doing this i'm apparently
invisible and i thought this only worked
in a wwe ring when my opponent was
incapacitated
but it actually also works on the
internet i think am i invisible
i don't know at points i think i am
and then there are points i wish i was
and then there are points
i know i'm not so i don't know if it's
dangerous but
i got a superpower so you can't see me
did it work what would the
favorite signature move of wwe of all
time
be without the two moves that i have on
my moves list
okay that leaves me a lot of options i
like the stone cold stunner
delivered by steve austin no offense
kevin owens but i think
steve austin's stone cold stunner what
would i
do first if i were president what would
i do first if i were president
i would turn the job down
if i had to pick what do i prefer acting
wwe or rapping um i know the release of
fast nine is enormous and it's amazing
to be part of the family but if you've
ever been to see wwe live
man it is just so special it would be
like
fast and furious unfolding in a packed
theater
of a hundred thousand people in real
time
as everyone's right there i don't think
there's
anything that compares to the to the
energy the spontaneity
and the involvement of the live
performance of wwe and i don't feel that
i'm shorting
hip-hop music or cinema by saying that i
just feel that i'm i'm giving wwe it's
just due
no come on okay okay i got it uh
five six five five no five four five
four but
in in in centimeters what am i i don't
even know what that is in inches
how tall am i in centimeters 32 no